[Music]
when will Lord sovereign your master of
basketball operations be arriving
they've entrusted me as emissary now
what is this trade thread no we've come
to discuss an alliance alliance how
would that even work
think of it more as a merger
individually our houses are weak but
together we can dominate the West as
house Kings swords don't love it all
done but what if I told you you could
play alongside the next Steph Curry
right it's just the name King Suns it's
awkward
what about sudden Kings okay fine from
here on we were House Sun Kings okay
we're the Sun Kings we've taken the
liberty of drafting a standard for our
new combined house buddy flip it one
more I can't really see the Sun it's at
the front of the crown excuse me I was
thinking maybe what I was thinking maybe
a crown inside a Sun like a fiery crown
I like that thanks you're not to paint
so I think about the compositions I
think it's great we want that the
flaming crown come on buddy it bogged in
spent like three practices stitching
this together it's fine it's fine my
lord it is a small price to pay for a
dragon dragon yes everyone is actually
quite keen to have a look
I mean trogon here is a [ __ ] dragon
where's its wings scales still
developing you guys come on oh I see so
the dragon is actually a person great
job researching bloody really good
researching there I didn't realize I
just read the notes the scouts gave me
they said dragon did you draft the Aaron
Fox because you thought it was a fox
foxes are smart it's fine it's fine we
can evaluate all our assets when we join
forces in Sacramento you mean in
Phoenicia Oh for heaven sakes we just
built a state-of-the-art castle isn't
Sacramento bit smooth just to go to
video 120 degrees every day it gets
cooler nights and besides do you expect
us to abandon a city with such a rich
basketball history
haha well clearly your
not familiar with the rich history of
house Kings Lord Commander a Durman and
his are lumen corner AFET I've come on
they don't even compare to D'Antoni
seven seconds unless a fat suit okey we
had Chris Webber
Sir Charles is better that's ridiculous
man Webber was bigger he was more
athletic not even close man
and you had nothing like pages per oggi
which he was no Dan Majerle right this
guy doesn't know what he's talking about
that Marley Dan Majerle was trash man
and I suppose you're going to say the
same of Steve Nash the Kings have never
come close to salad like that what about
a white knight of chocolate wait wait
wait did you just compare Jason Williams
to Steve Nash have you gone mental Steve
Nash never did in elbow Pass who gives a
[ __ ] what do you know about passing ball
all right enough enough maybe we are a
bunch of balls and maybe it is bloodier
than Phoenicia sure
Sacramento's small the Tucson I mean
know where it is to be honest but if we
put aside our differences and combine
our houses
well then still probably wouldn't make
the playoffs foot boy well when I look
around I see a bunch of guys who I may
not know their names and they may not be
good but they play basketball I think
and Eric make your point I guess my
point is I don't know I don't wanna be
here
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you